حسنًا ، فقط للتأكيد على ما قاله جون
كينج للتو ، هذا هو نادي
الصانعين
الذي لن يكون دونالد ترامب
جزءًا من
جيمي كارتر بوضوح أه لا يمكنه
السفر من أجل هذا
ولكن هذه مجموعة
يجب أن يكون
هناك رئيس سابق آخر في هذا  الصورة
اليوم
إذا كان قد ترقى إلى المكتب
ولم يفعل الشيء الآخر
بالإضافة إلى ما قاله جون كينج عن
وصول جو بايدن
إلى الرئيس بايدن ، عفواً الاتصال
به
للتحدث إلى
هؤلاء الثلاثة ، يمكنك أن تكون متأكدًا مما
قلته له بالفعل  إذا كان هناك أي شيء
تحتاجه ،
فنحن هنا من أجلك لكنهم يفهمون
أنهم محترمون لن
يتحدثوا علانية ،
وسوف يلتزمون بقانون
محاولة احترام وقته في المكتب ،
نعم هناك أنا أعرف حقيقة  أن أه
الرئيس السابق جيمي كارتر
البالغ من العمر 96 عامًا باركه الله به
96 عامًا كان سيحب أن
يشارك مع هؤلاء الرؤساء السابقين الآخرين
ولكن أه
في سنه آه كان ذلك ببساطة
مستحيلًا عليه مغادرة
سهول جورج  I ل